bonjour jean tawil et merci de répondre
à nos questions ce matin sur arte france
la première réunion de ce type a eu lieu
en août et a permis de récolter 250
millions d'euros d'aidé d'urgence
comment l'argent a été utilisé écoutez
comme vous avez bien présentés dans la
présentation et le reportage de ceux de
tout à l'heure aujourd'hui c'est très
important de savoir que la communauté
internationale et le peuple libanais
n'ont plus confiance en la classe
politique et ont les dirigeants du pays
aujourd'hui ce qui fait que même les
aides qui sont en train de venir des
aides internationales humanitaires qui
sont en train de venir au liban ne sont
pas en train de passer par les
institutions libanaises et par le
gouvernement libanais est entre les
mains de cette classe politique
libanaise
mais on est en train d'aller directement
pour aider le peuple libanais à travers
les organisations non gouvernementales
locales et internationales et même à
travers l'unicef et d'autres
organisations supranationales qui qui
sont présentes là pour s'assurer un de
la transparence et de la bonne gestion
de ces aides humanitaires qui sont en
train d'être dépensé au niveau et deux
pour être sûr que c'est le peuple
libanais qui malheureusement est on est
en train de vivre une crise sans
précédent qui sera en train lui même de
bénéficier et sans permettre à cette
classe politique de pouvoir mettre sa
main sur sur ces fonds là et de
continuer avec leur politique de
corruption et de gaspillage qui est leur
leur territoire tout ça pour dire donc
du coup que le gouvernement est donc la
place politique que vous dénoncez est
mise de côté dans ce dans ce processus
pourquoi parce que les promesses n'ont
pas été tenues c'est ça les premières
savoir que cette classe politique
elle tient en otage le peuple libanais
le peuple libanais est otage de cette
classe politique le peuple libanais qui
il ya un an
30% de la population libanaise vivaient
sous le seuil de pauvreté
aujourd'hui 55% selon le dernier rapport
de la banque mondiale 55% du peuple
libanais vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
ceux ci et là le résultat de cette prise
d'otages de cette catastrophe
humanitaire sanitaire économique social
politique qui est en train de se passer
au liban là cette prise d'otages s'est
justement manifesté par cette classe
politique qui n'a pas tenu ses
engagements pris auprès de la france et
ce qu'ils ont promis au président macron
justement ces promesses là on n'est plus
le peuple les dirigeants ne sont pas
censés le faire pour la france
ils sont pas censés le faire pour la
communauté internationale six
engagements c'est avant tout c'est pour
le peuple libanais et c'est pour le
liban depuis cette année comment comment
est-ce qu'ils accueillent ce rendez-vous
des donateurs emmanuel macron avait dit
récemment que paris et vis-à-vis de
beyrouth je cite dans l'exigence sinon
dans l'ingérence évidemment parce
qu'aujourd'hui la crise est tellement
grave que déjà à l'époque surtout après
l'explosion du 4 août
il est dans une situation psychologique
qui est catastrophique
il ya une dépression qui est en train de
se passer le peuple et des prix mais ici
il ya un brin engine qui est en train de
se passer ou les gens les pubs télé qui
ont le plus de qualités et de pouvoir
vraiment faire le changement dans ce
pays sont en train de partir ils ne se
retrouvent que ici legendary fiq lui
lesquels à l'image de la branche qui
co-organise
cette conférence des donateurs exigences
ou ingérence justement pour répondre à
ma question comment le ça ne peut pas
être une ingérence aujourd'hui lorsqu'il
ya des pays comme la france même la
communauté internationale qui est en
train de se mettre à côté du peuple
libanais pour aider le peuple libanais
alors que ses dirigeants
les dirigeants de ce peuple ne sont pas
là ils sont rares au contraire ils sont
complètement dans cette optique de
pouvoir se sauver eux-mêmes et de
pouvoir sauver leur clan c'est c'est le
problème c'est qu'on ne peut pas
considérer aujourd'hui cette aide comme
une ingérence au contraire c'est une
aide qui et qui très bien reçus parce
que justement la situation est tellement
grave que nous avons besoin de quoi que
ce soit pour pouvoir garder un peu la
tête au dessus de l'eau le temps de
pouvoir vraiment faire le changement
nécessaire voir le pays d'aller vers une
à quand bellity de cette caste classe
politique afin de pouvoir vraiment à les
tenir responsables et justes sont
justement les braises politique qui est
dans le viseur
de la justice trois ministres sont dans
le collimateur de la justice libanaise
je cite pour leurs responsabilités et
leur défaillance face à la gestion de la
présence dans le port de beyrouth de
nitrate d'ammonium
qu'est ce qu'on en sait de cette
procédure pour le moment écoutez ça fait
déjà ça fait déjà plus de trois mois
depuis l'explosion malheureusement
jusqu'à aujourd'hui à aucun responsable
qui a été tenue il n'y a aucun rapport
officiel ou responsable qui a été tenue
qui a été pénalisé le concernant c'est
ce massacre qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas compter sur le système
judiciaire libanais parce que c'est un
système judiciaire qui n'est pas
indépendant c'est un système judiciaire
où la politique est là une mainmise
dessus ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui tous
toute bataille contre la corruption ou
toute bataille juridique comme le
rapport ou bien l'investissement sion
sur le sur le sur l'explosion du 4 août
ne va jamais aboutir vous donnez un
résultat réel qui va satisfaire le liban
et le libanais parce que justement la
classe politique c'est elle qui a sept
ma mise dessus et ça c'est aussi une des
réformes essentielles que le liban
devrait entreprendre c'est d'aller
réformer le système judiciaire est
d'aller vers un système judiciaire
indépendant qui pourra réellement
prendre les décisions et combattre la
corruption
merci jean town et d'avoir répondu à une
question je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et président du conseil
économique et social du parti kataeb